y
[Música]
eeuu comienza a conversaciones
presenciales con el gobierno talibán en
doha habrá encuentros este sábado y
domingo con prioridad en la salida de
afganistán de estadounidenses y otros
extranjeros que aún siguen en el país
así como afganos colaboradores de
washington
el presidente de china xi jinping
prometió que realizará una reunificación
pacífica con taiwán la isla que se
declara independiente y gobernado
democráticamente rechazó las
declaraciones tras una semana de asedios
con aviones de combate enviados por
beijing elevando la atención en la zona
y un tribunal federal de apelaciones en
eeuu se restituyó la ley antiaborto de
texas sólo dos días antes un juez había
bloqueado temporalmente la normativa que
restringe la interrupción del embarazo
desde las seis semanas podría volver al
tribunal supremo que hace semanas
rechazo de estudiarla pese a cuestiones
sobre su constitucionalidad
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información internacional en france
eeuu en cara a la primera reunión con
los talibanes desde la retirada de sus
tropas en agosto cuando los extremistas
consolidaron a la toma de afganistán
representantes de ambas partes se
reunirán en doha este fin de semana con
el objetivo de evacuar a estadounidenses
que quedan en el país asiático junto a
otros extranjeros y a colaboradores
afganos también se discute la
reanudación de la ayuda humanitaria
entretanto el país asiático cientos de
familiares y residentes o asistieron a
ceremonias fúnebres en la ciudad de
kunduz tras el atentado que dejó más de
70 fallecidos este viernes
poco más de un mes desde que el último
soldado estadounidense abandonar
afganistán eeuu está celebrando su
primera reunión en persona con los
nuevos gobernantes del país los
talibanes las delegaciones llegaron a
doha en qatar este fin de semana el
departamento de estado de eeuu hizo
hincapié en que la reunión no supone el
reconocimiento del gobierno talibán
tenemos claro que cualquier legitimidad
debe ganarse a través de las acciones de
los talibanes
washington quiere garantías de que los
talibanes cumplirán su compromiso de
permitir que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses abandonen el país
decenas de ellos todavía están tratando
de salir junto con miles de afganos
elegibles para visas estadounidenses la
delegación norteamericana también quiere
que los talibanes permitan entrar a
ayuda humanitaria mientras el país
enfrenta una severa crisis económica la
reunión de dos días se produce poco
después de un atentado suicida con bomba
en la ciudad de kunduz al norte de
afganistán que mató a decenas de fieles
de una mezquita chií cientos de personas
acudieron a los funerales a despedir a
sus familiares y exigieron protección a
la autoridad talibán este ataque arroja
dudas sobre la promesa de los talibanes
de devolver la seguridad al país después
de décadas de violencia
les aseguramos a nuestros hermanos
chiítas que en el futuro les brindaremos
seguridad y que esos problemas no les
volverán a ocurrir
a toda la nación incluido en nosotros y
nuestros ancianos está de luto con ellos
eldad el ataque del viernes es sólo el
último realizado por la rama local del
grupo estado islámico los rivales de los
talibanes han intensificado una campaña
de ataques mortales desde la retirada de
eeuu en un intento por desestabilizar a
los nuevos gobernantes de afganistán
en otras noticias tras una semana de
tensiones el presidente chino xi jinping
prometió realizar una reunificación
pacífica con taiwán territorio que
reclama como propio la isla por su parte
respondió en rechazo de las
declaraciones de beijing haciendo un
llamado a que abandone sus intenciones
taipei que encabeza un gobierno
democrático independiente ha visto una
creciente presión militares china para
que acepte su soberanía desde el primero
de octubre la fuerza aérea de los chinos
realizó cuatro jornadas consecutivas de
incursiones en la zona de identificación
de defensa aérea de taiwán con cerca de
150 aviones
y
la reunificación completa de nuestro
país debe realizarse y puede realizarse
un juicio
con mí
la unificación es la esperanza de todo
el pueblo chino si china puede
reunificarse todos los chinos
disfrutarán de una vida feliz si china
no puede reunificarse todos sufrirán son
golden y piensan
jung woo nation
la independencia de taiwán es el mayor
obstáculo para la reunificación nacional
y un grave peligro oculto para el
rejuvenecimiento nacional aquellos que
olvidan su herencia traicionan a su
patria y buscan dividir el país no
servirán de nada y serán despreciados
por el pueblo y condenados por la
historia
si pasamos a noticias de españa en las
islas canarias la actividad sísmica se
incrementa en el volcán cumbre vieja en
la palma este sábado se derrumbó la cara
norte del cono de erupción y los
edificios cercanos quedaron
completamente cubiertos o por lava el
magma destruyó al menos cuatro edificios
en el pueblo de callejón de la gata y la
lava sigue avanzando hacia el mar
el llamado del tala vico ya llegó al
límite de la plataforma insular y corre
el riesgo de derrumbarse causando olas y
liberando más gases tóxicos
el volcán cumbre vieja entre una
erupción el 19 de septiembre y desde
entonces ha destruido más de 800
edificios y ha obligado a evacuar a unas
seis mil personas la ceniza ha detenido
el tránsito aéreo en el archipiélago
se conmemoran 40 años de la abolición de
la pena de muerte este día hace cuatro
décadas entró en vigor el cambio de la
ley y los franceses intentaron acabar
con el castigo durante doscientos años
antes de que fuera finalmente abolido en
1981 la legislación se aprobó bajo el
mandato del presidente socialista
françois mitterrand pero el abanderado
de esa lucha fue el infatigable abogado
robert badinter que llegaría a ser
ministro de justicia
sus palabras siguen resonando 40 años
después cuando afirmo a los legisladores
franceses que no hay hombres en la
tierra en quienes se deba perder
totalmente la esperanza en septiembre de
1981 joven bad under pidió formalmente
al fin de la pena de muerte alegando que
la justicia es humana y por lo tanto
falible
tengo el honor en nombre del gobierno de
la república francesa de someter a la
asamblea nacional la abolición de la
pena capital en francia la posición de
la péndulo
cuando josué metieron llegó a la
presidencia la pena de muerte seguía en
vigor incluso en su forma más
escalofriante la guillotina en aquel
momento francia era el último país de
europa con la excepción de belarús que
mantenía la pena capital y la opinión
pública estaba poco dispuesta a abolirla
pero para bud antes y un françois
mitterand aún no he elegido la república
debía construirse sobre valores no sobre
encuestas
no estoy en contra de la pena de muerte
y no necesito leer los sondeos de
opinión que dicen lo contrario una vez
elegido presidente emitió nombró abad
ante el ministro de justicia la
abolición de la pena de muerte se
convirtió en una prioridad para el nuevo
gobierno socialista pero se encontró con
una fuerte resistencia de algunos
sectores
cuando se suprima totalmente es cuando
los asesinos van a estar realmente
encantados no habrá límite
la abolición de la pena de muerte fue
finalmente promulgada el 9 de octubre de
1981 cuatro décadas después y a sus 93
años esa batalla no ha terminado para
balancear sigue luchando por la
abolición universal de la pena de muerte
que aún se aplica en 55 países
este domingo 10 de octubre se realizan
las elecciones parlamentarias
anticipadas en irak unos comicios que
llegan como consecuencia de las
manifestaciones lideradas por jóvenes en
octubre de 2019 para exigir un cambio el
fin de la corrupción y la lucha contra
el desempleo fueron banderas de cara a
estas elecciones sin embargo dos años
después y con el movimiento decantado se
espera una alta abstención de la
juventud soldados prisioneros y personas
desplazadas votaron en elecciones
tempranas mientras que el primer
ministro mustafa al kadim y anticipó que
no tomara partido por ningún candidato
en otros temas apenas dos días después
de que las clínicas de texas se
reanudarán los abortos para embarazos de
más de seis semanas un tribunal de
apelación de eeuu restableció la
prohibición del procedimiento en todo el
estado la ley de aborto más estricta del
país que prohíbe la interrupción del
embarazo en cuanto se detecta la
actividad cardíaca fue suspendida por un
juez del distrito estadounidense el
miércoles pero el fiscal general de
texas apeló con éxito el viernes por la
noche
han sido dos días muy ajetreados para
esta clínica abortista de houston pero
el aumento de las visitas ha durado poco
el viernes un tribunal federal de
apelaciones de eeuu dictaminó que texas
podría restaurar la prohibición de la
mayoría de las interrupciones
voluntarias del embarazo menos de 48
horas después de que otro tribunal
suspendiera tal prohibición la medida no
tardó en suscitar críticas entre los
activistas esta es una orden
profundamente alarmante que permitirá
que la prohibición del aborto en texas
vuelva a entrar en vigor en un momento
en que los proveedores de abortos
estaban comenzando rápidamente a
reanudar la atención al aborto para
todos los pacientes la ley del aborto en
texas entró en vigor el 1 de septiembre
prohíbe el procedimiento a partir de las
6 semanas de embarazo y no hace
excepciones para las víctimas de
violación o incesto la norma también
permite a los ciudadanos hacer cumplir
la prohibición recompensando les con
hasta 10.000 dólares por demandar a
cualquiera que ayude a facilitar los
abortos ilegales el miércoles por la
noche a un juez del distrito de eeuu
suspendió la restricción lo que hizo que
las clínicas de texas reanudarán los
abortos
pero esto fue anulado el viernes tras
una apelación del fiscal general del
estado que en paxton se dirigía a
twitter poco después de la decisión
calificándola de gran noticia y
prometiendo luchar contra la
extralimitación federal el gobierno de
bailén que presentó el recurso contra la
ley de texas tiene hasta el martes para
responder
las cifras de desempleo en eeuu no
cumplieron las expectativas de los
economistas y estuvieron a la baja en
comparación con el mes de agosto los
republicanos aprovecharon para criticar
a las cifras del gobierno de bailén y
dijeron que el paquete de ayuda para el
coronavirus de 19 billones de dólares
aprobado por el congreso no había
cumplido lo prometido andrés granadillo
nos cuenta más
unas cifras decepcionantes frente al
desempleo eeuu presentó los números de
empleo del mes de septiembre pero no
cumplieron las expectativas la pandemia
con el incremento de casos de la
variante delta es uno de los factores
que impide la mejora que esperaban los
estadounidenses la oferta y demanda de
empleos sigue desequilibrada parece que
esos problemas de oferta de mano de obra
no se han resuelto por sí mismos parece
que los trabajadores todavía están
luchando por salir y conseguir trabajo y
los empleadores todavía están luchando
por encontrar los trabajadores que
necesitan las empresas agregaron sólo
194 mil empleos en septiembre la mitad
de lo que habían pronosticado los
economistas con 500 mil puestos de
trabajo este desbalance no fue subrayado
por el presidente by de quien prefiere
fijarse en las cifras del desempleo que
suenan más optimistas today hoy por
primera vez desde marzo de 2020 la tasa
de desempleo estadounidense está por
debajo del 5%
en sólo ocho meses desde que asumí la
presidencia en medio de una grave crisis
de salud pública y económica la tasa de
desempleo está ahora por debajo del 5%
al 4.8 por ciento e impulsar los datos
de desempleo antes de la pandemia eran
del 35 % los 7 millones 700.000
desempleados estadounidenses tendrán que
esperar a que la economía siga mejorando
en los próximos meses a medida que
disminuyen las infecciones por kobe 19 y
las personas reanuden la búsqueda de
trabajo y para el cierre por primera vez
reguladores de seguridad sanitaria de
méxico rechazaron autorizar una nueva
variedad de maíz transgénico en unas
señales de que el gobierno está
endureciendo su posición en torno a los
cultivos son modificados genéticamente
la nación es autosuficiente en
producción de maíz blanco que se utiliza
para hacer tortillas el alimento básico
de los mexicanos pero depende en gran
medida de las importaciones de maíz
amarillo tanto para la alimentación de
ganado como para numerosos usos
industriales
el gigante de los pesticidas y semillas
transgénicas bayern perdió una batalla
en mexico el regulador sanitario del
país la cofepris rechazó un permiso para
una nueva variedad de maíz transgénico
solicitada por esa empresa farmacéutica
alemana se negó el primer permiso de
importación de las nuevas variedades de
semillas yimou bayern el regulador
determinó que la nueva variedad de
semilla estaba diseñada para tolerar el
herbicida glifosato una sustancia que
considera peligrosa por lo tanto dijo
que su rechazo se basaba en un principio
de precaución creo que aquí es una
especie de rescate cultural de nuestras
raíces de nuestra identidad porque al
final es de bueno no se ha probado pero
los seres humanos somos lo que nos
comemos la gigante farmacéutica bayer
declaró este viernes que está evaluando
sus opciones legales criticando la
decisión común o científica creo que es
un tema muy delicado que estamos dejando
que la ideología
o sea la que está detrás de la toma de
decisiones
y va a ser un error monumental
méxico cuna del maíz moderno nunca
permitió el cultivo escala comercial de
maíz transgénico pero durante décadas
gozó de la importación de estas
variedades aprobando unas 90 especies
modificadas pero bajo el gobierno del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien asumió el cargo a finales de 2018
la cofepris no aprobó ninguna semilla
transgénica
cada 30 minutos actualizamos las
noticias siguen en france 24 y en france
24 punto com buenos días
[Música]